wenn du deine eigenen tomaten anbauen
möchtest dann bist du hier genau richtig
ich zeige dir nämlich jetzt wieder
tomaten pflanzt sowohl im freiland als
auch im gewächshaus
[Musik]
bevor es mit dem pflanzen losgeht ist
eine sache aber ganz ganz wichtig das
ist das abhärten seine tomaten hast du
ja wahrscheinlich im haus vorgezogen
darüber habe ich ja auch schon mal ein
video gemacht und die sind es noch nicht
gewohnt wind und wetter und vor allem
der sonne ausgesetzt zu sein wenn du dir
jetzt einfach raus pflanzen würdest dann
würden die einen sonnenbrand bekommen
und ziemlich drunter leiden deswegen
gilt es die erstmal abzuhärten und dann
drauf schon zu gewöhnen dafür kannst du
die tomaten am ersten tag zum beispiel
erst mal für ein paar stunden in den
schatten stellen dann nimmst du sie
wieder mit ins haus am zweiten tag lässt
du sie vielleicht schon den ganzen tag
im schatten stehen und holst sie erst
abends ins haus und am dritten tag
können sie schon mal ein paar stunden in
der sonne stehen
danach kommen sie aber wieder in den
schatten und am letzten tag lässt sie
dann den ganzen tag in der vollen sonne
stehen es gilt also den tomatenpflanzen
ungefähr eine woche zeit zu sieben sich
nach und nach an das sonnenlicht zu
gewöhnen und auch daran zu gewöhnen dass
auf einmal wind weht das kannten wir
vorher auch nicht so dass sie sich so
ein bisschen darauf einstellen können
wie das große würde leben draußen im
beet aussehen kann
das geht ab wie thoma an die man ins
gewächshaus pflanzen will ja wann ist
der beste zeitpunkt um tomaten zu
pflanzen es kommt immer darauf an ob man
ein gewächshaus hat da kann man schon
ein bisschen früher pflanzen oder ob man
ins freiland pflanzen möchte oder in ein
tomaten häuschen das vielleicht nicht so
gut geschützt ist wie ein gewächshaus
für alle gewächshaus tomaten kann man je
nachdem wie das wetter ist schon ab
mitte april pflanzen das mache ich auf
jeden fall so weil es jetzt gerade sehr
warm ist bei uns da ist das gar kein
problem aber draußen ist es natürlich
noch ein bisschen zu kühl da muss man
bis nach den eisheiligen mitte mai
warten
die eisheiligen sind immer nur der
letzte termin im jahr an dem es frost
geben kann und dann kann man die tomaten
auch guten gewissens ins freiland
pflanzen weil die absolut keinen frost
vertragen deswegen ist es sehr wichtig
dass man darauf achtet dass sie es
möglichst warm haben und erst dann ins
bett kommen sind garantiert keine post
mehr drohen ja was ist der perfekte
standort für tomaten tomaten schaffen es
nach zu sein
die blätter sollten niemals sein und das
ist im freiland eben sehr
schwer die davor zu schützen weil man
nicht weiß wie der sommer werden wird
jetzt hatten wir gerade zwei sehr
trockene sommer davor der sommer war
aber so nass dass wir unsere ganzen
freiland tomaten schon im juli in die
tonne kloppen konnten weil die alle die
krautfäule bekommen haben und daran
zugrunde gegangen sind weil die gar
nicht abtrocknen konnten deswegen bau
ich meine tomaten am liebsten überdacht
an zb im gewächshaus ich baue aber auch
welche im kübel am haus an da sind die
so ein bisschen durch das haus und den
dachvorsprung geschützt dass es auch
schon viel viel besser als in einem beet
wo sie überhaupt nicht geschützt sind
einfach im freiland weil man eben klar
man kann davon ausgehen dass der nächste
sommer auch wieder sehr trocken und heiß
wird weil die letzten beiden sommer so
waren wegen klimawandel weil das der
frühling jetzt schon sehr trocken und
heiß ist oder sehr warm und deswegen
kann man schon erahnen wie der sommer
werden wird also wahrscheinlich ist es
in ordnung draußen freiland tomaten
anzubauen aber nachdem wir in diesem
jahr ich glaube das war 2000 17 oder 18
diesen unglaublich verregneten sommer
hatten und sowohl alle tomaten als auch
alle kartoffeln an diese blöde
krautfäule verloren haben bin ich da
sehr vorsichtig und versuche möglichst
alle meine tomaten überdacht anzubauen
ihr außerdem sind tomaten sehr sonnen
liebende gewächse die brauchen also ein
voll sonniges beet und die mögen einen
schönen humusreichen boden das passt gut
zu unserer methode wie wir gärtner an
dem drei phasen garten system wenn euch
das interessiert kann ich euch gerne
meinem gemüsegarten boot camp unten
verlinkten das ist mein gemüse garten
mini kurs und kostenloser dreiteiliger
videokurs wenn ihr euch gerne anschauen
könnt da zeige ich euch die wir diese
combo späte anbauen und die eignen sich
perfekt um tomaten anzubauen ich habe ja
eben schon über die krautfäule
gesprochen
das ist wirklich eine super fehse
krankheit die einem den ganzen tomaten
spaß verderben kann
deswegen ist es auch ganz wichtig dass
man selbst im gewächshaus wo die
pflanzen ja überdacht sind auf einem
großzügigen pflanzabstand achtet weil
die pflanzen immer gut abtrocknen müssen
und da muss immer ganz viel luft
zwischen den pflanzen zirkulieren können
weil das hält die gesund deswegen sollte
man bei tomaten 1 0
abstand von 50 mal 60 zentimetern
einhalten so dass jedes lanzl genug luft
und genug platz hat um abzutrocknen wenn
sie mal feucht geworden ist auch
kondenswasser soll möglichst gut
abtrocknen können und das ist ganz
wichtig das halte ich sowohl im
gewächshaus als auch draußen ein wobei
ich draußen er noch einen größeren
pflanzabstand wählen weil die pflanzen
leben draußen auch regen ausgesetzt sind
bevor ich meine tomatenpflanze möchte
ich mir immer einen cocktail aus uhr
gesteinsmehl hornspänen und apps im sold
ich weiß leider nicht genau wie das auf
deutsch heißt ich kann es euch aber
gerne in der video beschreibung
verlinken
von dieser mixtur wo ich ungefähr alle
drei komponenten zu gleichen anteilen
miteinander vermische davon gebe ich
dann ungefähr zwei esslöffel pro tomate
ins pflanzloch das locker ich immer ein
bisschen aus so dass sich ein bisschen
mit der erde vermischt dass die tomaten
nicht direkt darauf sitzen und dann
pflanze ich die tomate wie beim pikieren
auch einfach ein kleines bisschen tiefer
als sie vorher im topf gesessen hat so
dass sie bis zu den untersten blättern
im boden ist da können sich dann noch
mehr wurzeln bilden danach die tomaten
natürlich gut an gießen es ist auch ganz
wichtig wenn du deine tomaten im
gewächshaus pflanzen möchtest du hast du
dann darauf achtet dass sie nicht so nah
an der scheibe oder an der folie sind
weil die tomaten werden natürlich viel
größer wenn sie wachsen und dann
berühren die blätter ständig die scheibe
oder die folie und da damit sich dann
kondenswasser und das ist wieder ein
angriffspunkt für die krautfäule dass es
also ein sehr guter tipp habe ich auch
durch eigene erfahrung einfach gelernt
dass man die tomaten immer ein stück
weit von der wand entfernt pflanzen muss
damit das nicht passiert wenn du bist
tomaten anbauen möchtest dann brauchst
du keine rankhilfe die anderen tomaten
brauchen aber irgendeine form höhe von
stütze dafür nämlich manchmal
eisenstangen im freiland es gibt auch
extra tomaten stangen die man verwenden
kann und im gewächshaus finde ich es am
praktischsten wenn man oben unterm dach
3d spannt von denen aus man dann schnell
herunter führen kann die knotet man
einmal unten am wurzelhals fest mit
einer lockeren schlaufe und dann kann
man die pflanzen immer um die schnüre
drumrum wickeln während die größe
wachsen da haben die dann auch einen
super halt und was sich dabei auch noch
super gerne mache ist dass ich das obere
ende der schnur
ein bisschen länger lasse so dass man
dann am ende wenn die pflanze oben
angekommen ist an der schnur die schnur
noch mal runter lassen kann so dass die
tomaten dann ein bisschen durchhängen
aber immer noch weiter wachsen können
dann kann man am ende mehr früchte von
der pflanze ernten und muss die nicht so
bald oben abbrechen wenn sie das dach
erreicht hat das ist nur ganz wichtig
dass wenn sie dann so auf der erde hängt
mit dem unteren teil dass man dann die
blätter die die erde berühren ab macht
auch wieder wegen der krautfäule die
ganz leicht vom boden auf die pflanze
überspringen kann
da oben sind die drähte die wir spannen
um die tomaten daran aufzuhängen
ich hoffe sie die auf der kamera und
daran binden wir dann die schnüre
anliegen wie die tomaten hochladen nicht
wundern dass da gerade spinat neben der
tomate wächst dass es eine so genannte
zwischen pflanzung der spinat
der ist bald erntereif da kann man jetzt
schon einzelne blätter ernten und bald
ist er abgeerntet und dann hat die
tomate den klasse für sich war im moment
wäre der platz da hinten ja komplett
ungenutzt und so können wir den jetzt
noch mit dem spieler hat nutzen und
später kann die tomate dina ganz für
sich allein beanspruchen bzw
bekommt er noch eine basilikum
unterpflanzung hin weil tomaten und
basilikum eine tolle mischkultur sind
aber das basilikum 490 dann immer etwas
weiter von der tomate entfernt so dass
die genug platz haben und sich selbst
auszubreiten ja und das war es auch
schon wenn du das alles beachtet dann
bist du super aufgestellt für eine
reiche tomatenernte ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim tomatenpflanzen
sobald das nächste tomaten video in
meiner serie erscheint kann ich euch das
gerne hier trügen verlinken
bis dahin findet ihr hier und hier
andere videos die euch interessieren
könnten vielleicht schaut ihr da ja mal
vorbei bis nächste woche ich freue mich
auf euch